all righty I think it's time to start
let's give it a go hello everyone we're
happy here to be here in Sydney first
time for me first time in a DC Sydney
first time in Australia and New Zealand
nearby right I'm gonna talk about async
demystified today and here's something
that you should expect from from this
dog I'm gonna go for the history of
async patterns in dotnet and then look
at the kind of history and evolution of
tasks and async/await including value
tasks some kind of catches you know
what's kind of behind the scenes I you
know try this talk in some couple of
local user groups and one feedback was
that the first half is kind of boring
for some people however other people
find it useful so I still keep it in so
I apologize if you're in the first group
you might be bored for you know first
off and just that you know kind of all
bit context on this talk this is not
something I came up you know you know
entirely on my own this is actually
rehash of something that the the father
and author of the you know of the
async/await and all the sickness things
Steven told it internally and then I
heard that I was like oh my gosh this
thing has to get out like this is gold
that finally made me kind of understand
a little bit more and deeper appreciate
async/await stuff so this is one can
present over here and hopefully you're
gonna get same value that I did from
that so let's start with history a long
long time ago in Docklands framework 1.0
in 1.1 which is Wow 16 years 18 years
ago
that's or something like that that's per
day that's pretty far far out we
invented something called APM APM
patterns stands for asynchronous
programming model and what was literally
it was a thing where we had a ia sync
result interface we had a couple of
things on it one was is completed its
complete its synchronously those are
boolean's it had some object async state
usually custom and made handle for the
async
like a sink wait handle which usually
was like you know manual reset event or
outer is settlement and you know this
thing was you know cool back then it was
you know spread across BCL the core
effects and the typical function you
would see in NBC L was something like
this like there was like begin foo which
takes call back
it takes the state and then and foo
which would take the ia sync result that
the begin foo created or kind of
returned the usage of the api's like
never basically two ways how to use it
either you would wait for the callback
you would call the you know beginner
fool you would wait for the callback to
be called and then inside you would call
the n foo or the other option that you
had is actually to directly call the end
foo and block that thing would block
until that the asynchronous thing ended
so you had two ways how to use it let me
it's actually let's look at that how it
looks in code so synchronous call would
look like this you have a foo method is
alternative and many functions in bcl-xl
have both synchronous and asynchronous
stuff would be begin foo and and foo
couple and to achieve exactly the same
thing as calling the synchronous
synchronous fool using the asynchronous
thing you would do this it would call
and foo on the begin foo and just passed
now for callback now for object state
magic happens basically the same thing
now to take advantage of the
asynchronous nature obviously you would
not do that like that
why why would you do the synchronous
when you can do a Cygnus the whole pie
the whole point of asynchronous is
actually to be a sickness to take the
advantage you would call the begin foo
and you would create their lambda
callback and inside you would basically
as I said called and foo on
on the icing results that was created
from the big info and it would get the
value but value out of that and do some
stuff anyway
thirdly is the pattern you know sounds
good right now this works fine when you
have one single operation
it breaks down badly when you need
something more complicated especially
very for example you're passing things
between streams or something like that
you need usually like more than one
operation it's rare that you do it like
hey one a sync operation I'm done it's
like you know copy I don't know 10
kilobytes buffers across streams or
something like that until end and it's
usually a loop so how would that look
like
in a loop imagine that relay just said
you're copying a stranger stream so
normal code would look something like
this the synchronous version you would
read from the input into a buffer you
would get information how much Beth
bites all right
and usually zero is the you know
notification how you're done
get away and inside you would just like
take the buffer and pass it somewhere
else
imagine that this is for example taking
I don't know disk you know you're
reading from disk one stream and you're
sending it to network or the other
opposite like you're reading from
network saving it to disk or saving to
memory to process it all a bit further
so fairly simple how would it look like
you know in an APM in the asynchronous
way because doing that synchronously
kind of sucks so you would have the
begin rate that's what we've seen before
you would pass the you know past the
callback and the callback the first
thing it would do it would call and read
on that once you have to enter it from
the input what do you want to do with
that you want to call the right to call
the right you want to do it as well so
you would begin right on the input
that's a bug in the code sorry for that
you would you know invoke the begin
right again in the in the callback of
the right you would call and right and
what do you want to do after so that's
basically the one iteration there's the
single operation after that you want to
go on so you do begin read inside and
operate then do you begin right and
again again again and you probably you
know
do computer science for a while you know
that it doesn't scale you know you know
it does not work at all so the thing
actually you need to do is to turn this
into loop and I don't try it myself but
apparently it's extremely long and
tricky and very few people do get it
right so that's kind of this kind of
sucks and on top of that like this is
kind of the happy path not happy path
it's actually not happy path when
everything is asynchronous
but in practice oftentimes you get
actually sin has come you know a lot of
fun times but in certain scenarios it's
quite common that you get synchronous
completion of the asynchronous tasks so
we do with that that actually
complicates stuff even more I'm going to
look at it in the next side so it's
completely synchronously you know when
he you know why would you kind of want
to deal with that first of all you want
to leave that for performance reasons
because if you have the data available
instead of like you know spanning in
other tasks why scheduling it on fret
pool and that stuff if you have this
stuff over there just like go and deal
with that at the moment so the good code
would look actually something like this
inside inside a callback you would first
think you would say like hey did it
complete synchronously and if not then
you would do the asynchronous path
otherwise you will fall back and do
something different right behind which
means that you will have you know have
if check like hey if it is completely
completed synchronously do do
synchronous path actually there's quite
a few BCL functions or you know
especially on networking and other stuff
inside BC actually have exactly this
pattern now this is not that great
because it has like several programs
first of all before the loop that I said
before in just the second isolationist
way was complicated this makes it even
like you know another level more
complicated so that's a no-go very you
know and overall actually you know
people would leave but people read it
then doing something like this they said
like you know what let me just like put
everything on fret tool and that's gonna
be easy
you know that's kind of asynchronous as
well and you know let me know do the
performance improve improvements and
everything so that kind of sucked now
when you look at that
the kind of is actually another problem
on top of what I said and the problem is
that imagine that you have something
like memories stream when you're passing
things around and it's actually you know
basically a memory stream typically the
data is available right away
so what's gonna happen is that if you
have this loop this beautiful loop very
complicated right you have all if checks
and stuff
you take the take the completed
synchronously path all the time because
you you know the memory is just
available maybe maybe you do you know
compression in memory or something like
that right what is what's gonna happen
you're gonna have actually in this loop
you're gonna you're gonna get actually
records if callbacks
you know recursive calls because you're
not just looping but whenever you need
to call the next step you're gonna call
it yourself and after roughly ten
thousand you know records of course
you're gonna stack overflow so that's
yet another thing to kind of worry about
and something that kind of complicated
things so overall you know it was it's
complicated and you know even in BCL we
can have lots of wrappers around these
things and working something called lazy
async result in the implementation
inside and there's lots of
specializations and overall very
complicated kind of rocket science code
and actually I had the opportunity to
run into that pro last year in
networking I was like oh my gosh what is
this doing and we had actually security
bugs around that because buffer
management because you don't know when
things come back and what you can
release and just like pure nightmare
nightmare all right one day a little bit
later in dotnet framework 2.0 we decided
like let's do something better or oh I
should say better we Pro let's try for
do something better we did something
different we did event based a
synchronous Potter EAP and it was very
similar in its nature as the previous
day I am a p.m. accepted use events so
over here you would kind of like hook up
events of it like Sandra and event arcs
and live was fairly beautiful now you
know it's very straightforward idea and
the the handler would be kind of
involved generally by Fred pool the
callback when it was completed like you
know cool right
the problem is that it did not solve
actually the multiple calls problems or
loops so the stuff that I showed before
it has exactly the same problems
apparently we decided that it will
decide we realize that right after
shipping or very quickly but yeah we try
to improve things but we did not
actually help with the key programs so
it was kind of an interesting experiment
but didn't really go anywhere in BCL
it's actually used at a couple of
classes especially I'm not working like
SMTP client TCP client and background
worker around thread pool and that stuff
so it is some use but overall it didn't
kind of kick off much we didn't kind of
push for it either
it was you know interesting experiment
but one important thing that came out of
that was actually execution context
which you might have heard about you
know it's something
imagine that it's something like you
know a sink low go so something that
flows with your asynchronous you know
flow through the frets no matter where
you kind of execute so you have a place
baby were to kind of put things in and
actually a sink logo is built on top of
that in later future versions so even
though it's kind of like you know sucks
that we introduced something that was
not useful at least kind of some side
effects very useful eventually so let's
move to you know next step and that
eventually
afterwards task came around and it was
in actually dotnet framework 4.0 which
again is probably a few years and
interesting that it was created as a
part of MSR which is Microsoft Research
now and it was strictly about parallel
computing it was has nothing to do with
IO and stuff like originally it was
really for you know how to do
efficiently on some unified way some
divide and conquer so imagine quicksort
right you know we learn it at school so
if you went to school if you're not
self-taught and that stuff where you
kind of do quicksort you're going to
make the pad be what you say the left
side sort me left side right side do it
recursively divide conquer when you have
results you can emerge it
together so that's what the goal was now
you know we got there it kind of shaped
the task and honestly like you know how
it shaped the task how it created that
that state until today and it's
interesting you know note from Steven
that he made is that you know you know
the task is pretty good you know it's
light weight nice you know is they to
think about it's roughly 90 percent all
the things in there are right and 10
percent until today still they gave up
at night even after 10 years so I would
love to change it but obviously
compatibility everything people depend
on that not gonna happen
sorry so what is that task and if you
didn't didn't kind of run into that
before it really truly represents
something general general work it
doesn't care if it's compute if it's IO
it's not tied to Fred pool which is the
beautiful thing I mean almost not tied
to Fred pool we're gonna get to that you
know it's really about you know not
exactly it's not tied to the execution
it just represents the war the work you
can call it in other languages like
promise future or other terminology but
it's basically the same thing you can
shove results into it you can it can be
completed and it can wake up somebody
who's waiting on the task that's roughly
what it does so that we have two
versions task and task of T one is
generic basically what would return
operation return value is that's the T
if it's white then you have the
non-generic part task and what it
contains as I said like first of all it
returns the value T in case of the task
of T for task it's white so there's
nothing it has some state right to
synchronization and as well as some
state related to to callback that you're
going to have to call or somebody has to
go now that starts it just represent
things there's a beautiful thing called
task completion source which not many
people run into if you're consumers of
the tasks only and the task completion
source is something that actually are
actually coming back first to task task
it actually is something that you know
you consume you use it you kind of hook
up to that and you say like in hey when
you're done
you know call me or if you're done
already just call me right now but you
basically hook up yourself to something
you if you have a task in hand or
somebody gave you a task you're not
given the opportunity to actually do
something about it like change its state
that is the role of the task completion
source so as I said like you know the
task is something that you can tell it
like you know hey I have callback you
know when you're done or you know even
right now when you're ready and it's
completed call me back
the other thing that is inside is that
hey or you can use it for is like you
know I want to block until it's done so
like you know not giving call back but
kind of wait on you and the other thing
you cannot really complete it directly
by the user now that's a good thing
there's this task completion source
which is actually wrapper around tasks
which is interesting
it calls internal method methods on the
task itself to actually change its state
and that stuff but the beauty of the
desk completion source it is something
that if your producer of such work like
for example networking or whatever you
know I owe you don't give it away
because you give it only to trusted
people or trusted colors that you know
are not gonna mess up in your workflow
because imagine you know you're reading
something from network or something like
that and somebody suddenly decides like
if you're done like well I'm not done I
you know so you know you want to be in
charge of when things are done when
things are you know when you're ready to
kind of move and make it complete it so
the task completions are first kind of
like changes you know under new hood the
task they're free base which is either
you set result which means that if you
complete it I know you read some data
from some stream or something
you set result or there was an exception
happening during the time maybe lost
connection or something you can set
exception or it has been cancelled from
the user in that case you say hey it's
cancelled so we were done and it's gonna
be some canceled exception later on
right let's move on the consumption so I
said the task how its consumed you know
we have a task leak and you know either
you can wait on it so you do t to plate
that usually creates the manual reset
event and it will be signal later with
you know if you call the one of the free
methods or task completion source if it
calls the set set results if exception
or set cancel or you can do the you know
not blocking way and say like you know
hey here's my callback you know when
you're done with it you know just call
me back the beautiful thing on that that
you can call it multiple times or it
doesn't have to be only you there can be
multiple consumers of the same time task
who kind of hook up to that and say like
you know hey please wake me up or call
me back when you're done so this is how
you can hook up into it and the
interesting thing that it does not
guarantee you no order of execution so
it doesn't matter in which order you're
going to hook up the callbacks and it's
always asynchronous so it doesn't have
any you know synchronous way except
there's a overloaded tax execution
option and we can dance in here and
sleep up in you're gonna get into that
and if you look at this like you know
why is this so much better or than what
we talked at the beginning the APM the
key difference is that you know in the
APM and ia sync result and the original
you know asynchronous pattern we didn't
have any chart implementation over here
you actually you can share lots of code
because the continuation is not specific
to the call you don't have to pass the
delegate at the creation time so you can
have like generic code and then whoever
needs to kind of be woken up later on is
gonna hook up to that that's kind of
like very small thing but actually it
enabled lots of interesting things and
we will see later in the talk that
actually that's what the async await
uses exactly you know behind who the
compiler actually hooks up to these
tasks to be called back into some
generated code and execute geometry
method on your behalf
you know small thing but change the
world now let's talk about the thing
that keeps different up up in night you
know we did this function test run which
is convenient method every month of it
the trouble is that it makes up things
it basically this is ty to fret pool
because what it does it actually creates
the task runs on that fret pool and
there's
if you remembered as I said task is in
general like representation of work it
doesn't care about first one I think
except this one and on top of that to
kind of implement that you know you know
this is how the task doctrine looks like
we actually
editfield to the task just to support
this which kind of sucks so we kind of
made it larger and actually don't know
if we fixed it but I'm gonna see
actually why we think it's bad as I said
it cues the work on the fret pool you
know some fret will grab it execute
whatever think and then mark the task
completed so it's a convenient method
obviously people of it because it's
useful but any other day you know it
complicated things because it's kind of
suddenly everyone things like oh now
look around it creates the frets like
and their mindset is that hey tasks are
about frets which is actually not the
fact so we kind of complicated for
people to understand it and on top of
that kind of messed up with with our
implementation so what if we said like
hey you know why don't we do it simpler
there's actually why how to implement
astute ROM you know with existing things
that I just showed you and it's well
nicely demonstrates how you would use
tasks and task completion source
actually so what do you do first we say
you know inside you get like hey I'm
supposed to execute this delegate F and
I'm supposed to return some task of T
after that so we would create the task
completion source because you're the
person who will generate the work you
don't put it away you would that Q some
work on the on the thread pool that
would do what it would execute exactly
what you were told to execute and once
you're done you have some result you
will set it on the task completion
source now and then eventually at the
end you will return the task out of the
task completion source which I might
because it's basically as I said before
it's the wrapper around task the task
completion source and cause the internal
methods right it's obviously in retail
bit more complicated you have some
try-catch exceptions are think you know
and you do something else with them in
this case the step exception and there
would be probably you know it's optional
the cancellation you know stuff you
probably not have to listen to that if
and in this case you don't even want to
now the task that you return out of this
can be awaited on and if you look at
that it's not that complicated it's
actually fairly simple yet we
unfortunately messed up our
implementation so yep mistake has been
made
let's go to async await so little bits
positive no so that thing came out in
dotnet framework 4.5 just basically the
next larger version after the 4.0 where
the task came in you will see the
pattern that we introduced pieces and
then the next release finally starts
building on them in a meaningful way
which is kind of cool and we're going to
look at some kind of example of
asynchronous call so imagine that you
have methods like get data by the way
the async is you if you did a sink in
that you probably know that async suffix
is typically say like hey I'm a
task-based kind of like you know
you know convention basically for the
methods so imagine that you have get
data put data let's say does something
across network or i/o or something like
that you just like throwing people
offering data here and they're not
people I believe that you know now how
would it look like
we would first call the get toss a get
data async then you would hook up a
continuation on that and say like you
know hey when you call me back which
means when the thing is done I want to
put that into some you know a sink into
you know put the data on the other
stream on the other side and that's just
for the fun printout we're done after
we're done you know something like that
obviously you don't want to write code
like this so how would this code which
is exactly the same look like with the
you know async await you would start the
same you know get that I think you get
tasks of T and if we would just evade
the T away the task you would get a
result which is the a dot result
basically in the code above you would
put you would take the result and do
something with them like you know on the
other side put data I think you will get
another task and what we do on that you
would await it that think returns white
if you notice the put because it doesn't
have an information just like
information like a I'm done and after
you're done you can go and write line
you're I'm done fairly simple and next
if you look at that you know the code
above is roughly what the compiler
generates for you
you know the c-sharp compiler now it's a
little hand waving because it's a little
bit more complicated from the
perspective that compiler doesn't know
specifically about tasks even that has
small strings I'm gonna get to that but
it looks for so-called evader pattern so
and task is one of the things that is a
waiter which was actually very smart at
we kind of it's kind of basically a duck
typing you know if anything looks like
task it can treat it this way we're
going to get to what what does it mean
the Vator pattern in there and it
actually enabled us us as you will see
later on to ship similar things which
can deliver even more things that we
couldn't imagine at the time we ship
this thing so we made it you know
generalized enough instead of shipping
interfaces and stuff that kind of you
know bound you into certain things how
you have to behave and thanks to the
elevator pattern actually it improve us
to you know innovate later on even more
so let's look at the aviator pattern how
would this think that we've seen in the
code before look like so if you have
eight tea and you get a result out of it
it's actually translated by compiler
into something like this you get T dot
get away tur
which doesn't you know you don't know
what the tech you know even compile
doesn't know what it is the only thing
that it kind of needs it's kind of few
methods in there one of them is
completed and that thing has to return
bull or a bull and if it's not
complicated you do something we're going
to get to that later and if it is
complicated then you call the get result
the methods involved are exactly those
things that compiler looks for in the
tasks like or innovator pattern and not
is completed thing is a little bit more
complicated we're gonna get to that a
little bit later it's shown next slide
and basically what it has to do is
someone has to it has to hook up some
code that you know it because if it's
not completed means that it's running
asynchronously you don't want to block
on that place the whole point of the
async is that you don't block parts but
you need to somehow hook it up and make
sure that next time the vendor thing is
completed you're gonna go and resume the
egg
in this method after the after this and
then I'm not gonna going this talk about
details but you can totally imagine that
you're awaiting multiple things in a
method right you know we have large my
taught you have a days away that with
that and like so all that thing can be
multiple you know multiple things and
your method so the complicated thing
inside and just you know make sure that
we're gonna go and dig into that so this
is the same code or piece of it and as
the knot is completed and then they get
result and we gonna kind of return so
you know let's look into deeper into
that so first of all all this is part of
the method which is called to move next
and the movement makes the method is
basically it's a state machine so you
have state and you when you can only get
into the knot was completed you say like
you know hey I am in this state return
and when you come back you will know
that hey this is the state you have been
in let me I know where to continue next
so the state machine has some states for
example state zero and this is one of
the probably only or few valid uses of
go-to otherwise don't use it please but
you know in the state 0 we go to label 0
lead 1 what do you do and it's complete
it it's some you know it's somewhere in
the middle so let's say it's you know
state 42 because it's a good number
right as we all know when you know you
set it and then you call another thing
on the Vator pattern that's the
uncompleted you basically tell the
waiter like you know which is the task
like thingy like hey when you're done
please call the move next and in between
or in the meantime you saved in your in
your state in the in your state where
you should resume and not surprisingly
at the beginning you're gonna check like
hey if i'm the state 42 next time you
call me i need to resume where i was
before
so right after the note is completed so
that's how it's done
now the uncompleted is a little bit more
you know complicated signature and i'm
gonna go into those details and let's
look a little bit deeper into how does
the state machine actually look like so
imagine that you have a code like this
you read something from a user you know
x you then you know independently evade
thing from network or whatever you know
some pacing and then you want to write
line something like hey I'm done and buy
divide X was something important as you
can see you know or as we as we talk
about the a twill basically I'll
interrupt you know just going to move
next and there's gonna be kind of
interrupted call and when we come back
you know the question is like you know
how does the X actually survive debate
right you know because it's different
calls so there's gonna be state machine
created by the compiler on your behalf
let's say this is method foo so there's
gonna be matter to state machine it's
gonna have to move next something that
we have seen before
it's gonna have the locals so the X from
this code will be one of the locals
that's gonna be captured in that state
machine it's gonna have parameters of
the method because they need to survive
usually and it's gonna have the you know
evader and as well state a Vater is
basically you know generated you know
dynamically based on whatever it return
so it can be different type all the time
now the this trick is similar to you
know if you've seen lambdas and how they
kind of do the closure and capture all
your locals this is the machine is
basically the same thing it's not rocket
science
now interestingly and like not
surprisingly compiler obviously
optimizes optimizes things so if the X
would not would not kind of cross the
evade boundaries
it would not be put inside a state
machine because there's no point why
would you store locals which you will
not need later so you know it's trying
to be nice to you to everyone
and another thing you probably notice
that it's struct its struct from perf
reasons but if you have structs it kind
of sucks in debug because finding them
and you know you know on the heap and
whatnot is extremely difficult
you cannot enumerate like what's in
flight if you have a dump and that stuff
so actually in debug mode which is
interesting this is a class which
obviously allocates I'm gonna get to
performance and that stuff and the
reason why it is struct now imagine that
you have something like buffered stream
so you read a buffer 10k and then you
know that you know and the user or
whoever calls you
you're just gonna return pieces and
let's say the user is like
calling and reading always one bite for
example and you're at the 10k right so
then each call if it would be you know
you know we're gonna see that later if
it would be actually you know class you
would allocate state machine per each
page of this calls of the read now if
it's struct and if it completes
synchronously because it's buffered
because you read the 10k you have it in
memory just can immediately return with
this struct you can avoid actually these
allocations because everything is on the
stack so that's the one kind of key
motivation for the performance why it's
a struct but in the in debug its class
for debug ability already let's move on
and let's actually look at example of
such state machine so over here you know
method foo takes time out and inside we
just cause something task delay timeout
and a weight on it so classic you know
wait wait for so many seconds very
simple thing how would the state machine
look like so it would have the parameter
timeout we talked about that it would
have locus if there were any crossing
the boundaries there are none so just a
comment it will have the move next
method as we said it will have the state
and later information which is actually
tasks evader and the compiler generates
on top of that instead of the you know
async foo it generates a real public foo
which is not async and inside what you
do first thing you go and allocate the
state machine
it's a struct so boom default beautiful
you will you got the timeout so you
store it in the state machine you
initialize the state and you move next
because the all the logic is actually
inside the move next method and then you
return something we're gonna get you
know it needs to be a task we know that
it's a bit more complicated we're gonna
you know expand on that in the next
slide so how would this work we're gonna
keep the foo method and and the state
machine and as you have seen the
formatter is now a little bit larger
missing the bottom curly braces sorry
for that but it's basically you know
same thing that we saw and on
on the slide before not much changed so
what we will have here actually yeah I
messed up the slide that it doesn't show
in the right order sorry for that but
the timeout state and move next was from
the previous slide and the thing
actually we need to do this is in the
wrong order oh my goodness
sorry so on the state machine we would
have the task completion source on top
of that so that's the last field I edit
and actually it's something that we move
in the move next we would set result on
if you remember again like you know to
return the task the task completion
source is the thing that kind of
generates and completes the task right
and even though that this is a field
over here it's logically there it's
actually more complicated I'm gonna get
to that a little bit later and in the
full machine the first thing that's new
is that we allocate the task completion
source in there and then we're going to
return the task which is inside the task
completion source you know fairly fairly
straightforward now there are two
problems here problem number one
performance there are two allocations in
this code one is the task completion
source and the second is actually the
task inside the task completion source
so pair each call you're gonna do two
allocations which you know imagine again
the buffered stream you know when you
have the 10k and you call it one bite
each like you allocate pair each call to
two objects kind of sucks the other
problematic thing is that as I said a
compiler tries to not know anything
about tasks it's a white lie a little
bit but almost anything so it has the
Vator pattern and the same way you know
it tries to not understand that there's
a task completion source because that's
tied to really specifically two tasks so
instead of this you know task completion
sources what we have is you know builder
pattern so instead of the MU of task
completion source you're gonna find the
right builder just some magic I'm gonna
describe and then call create on that
the huge advantage of that that think
because you're just looking for create
method and whatnot of the write builder
can return a structure which means again
if you complete synchronously you don't
have to allocate so with that you're
going to get rid of the allocation of
the
completion source which is awesome and
obviously like if you have the Builder
like that instead of storing the TCS
you're going to store the Builder and
the Builder inside has like another you
know the the pattern is tasks and that's
something that you would return in the
code above so a little bit generalized
but you know not a super huge thing we
actually we actually have this exactly
thing for the value task that's the
specific metal builder I put there in
there and how does she sharp compiler
finds for your thing what's your write
builder
it actually looks for I think everywhere
for a for an attribute on types which
basically tell the compiled I am builder
for that thingy over there so it it know
it can stitch just through kind of
attributes all these things without
knowing anything about tasks and task
completion source all its kind of tasks
like which is kind of cool just FYI
internally we have actually you know
structs for the async task method
builder which is for the tasks we really
have that method method builder we have
the async task metal builder of T for
the you know generic case and as well
for the async white metal builder and
that's probably as much as I can say on
this slide so we with this builder we
enable the option especially for various
tasks too you know eliminate one
allocation in there per call which is
cool
still there's this task in there so what
do we do about that one thing that
actually you can do first of all the
builder you know the you know for
example for the value tasks can reuse
known tasks in this case that's what we
kind of enable for example there can be
tasks your complete and there is cosgood
completed tasks which just represents
that hey be undone I don't return
anything void but you know I'm done
why would you create instance of that
per each you know per each goal as soon
as you have that case you can always
return this thing and you can reuse that
we have actually for butene there are
only two options there's like can have
value true or false you know
bus bus that can have like any value in
there which is good so that enables us
to to actually optimize for you know
having two values and based on that we
return we return to predefined values we
have four integers like there's lots of
numbers but from unknown reasons to me
we have specific values for -1 and 8
inclusive you know probably we did some
research somewhere that it's kind of
useful 0 to 8 is probably like the
typical size that returns in something
and minus 1 like error I don't know
anyway we have those things buffered and
another thing actually we you can you
know the Builder can as well cash the
last completed one which imagine that
it's a memory stream that you read
chunks of memory you're somebody who
reads 4k or somebody else reach 8k but
they usually do the loop so each call
typically except the last one when you
you know read the rest or whatever is
remaining is the same so you can reuse
that reuse that thing so that's cool
unfortunately does not work for example
for SSL stream SSO stream is this thing
I'm gonna do SSL because you know or
HTTP you have the headers which you kind
of do a you kind of sorry you you will
kind of encode encrypt and then the body
and they are usually different sizes so
for something are abhi would have to
invent that you have lost two to last
completed things and alternate between
them because again typically they will
be probably you know similar or same
size and you know that's how you avoid
you know they will not be the numbers
between minus 1 and 8 but something
larger
another thing actually that you know
prepare for improvements that we can
look at is that you know the size of
this thing is actually 64 bytes or 72
bytes based on if you have value or not
if it's bit white and you know that is
kind of okay in Azure more clothes or in
the cloud like you know GC will collect
the bytes and whatnot but you know if
you're on a hot path and there are cases
like that it kind of kind of imprint no
hurt your performance up to five to ten
percent because by inducing more GCS
right I know it's kind of overall if you
kind of hammer that I'm at its if it's a
whole path that really shows up a lot
for example
no sockets you know when you do
networking and that stuff that's
actually when it matters so we went and
invented something called value task
which I already hinted it was dope net
core 2.0 it's available as well for
downlevel which means not net framework
and like.net core previous versions even
though none of them are supported
anymore and it's fairly simple it has
basically two values it has either
holstee or it holds tasks of T and all
the methods are basically one-liners it
was so before jumping to that you know
it can logically hold only one thing you
know only one of those things is normal
or you know valid either the T and then
the task is to be now or the T is
default and then the task of T is the
real value and based on that chicken
just you know on the task of teaching
for now you can do basically one-liner
things what to do you know which one it
is you know you can quickly decide so
implementations fairly fairly simple and
all this evader thing is and that stuff
that actually you know that's what
allowed us to create the value tasks
because it's tasks like it behaves like
that but because we were smart in the
compiler number thing you know we didn't
kind of require like it has to be tasks
and everything we had the option to
actually create value tasks which is a
struct which means it you know we will
avoid actually allocation you know if
it's the synchronous case obviously now
if you think about that that's awesome
we have value tasks but we already had
by the time lots of functions that
return tasks so what do you do we cannot
overload on return parameter return type
right luckily in the.net core 2.1 we
introduced the span and memory of T so
that allows us and we had to add a bunch
of overloads in you know NB C L so what
we could do is actually when we edit the
you know memory of byte overload for
example on some stream or something we'd
say like you know what don't return the
task return to the value task it's gonna
be a little bit faster and as that you
know nice interesting thing that
sometimes you CPRS incur effects when
people pass around you know byte array
and the PR is basic like you know
to byte array in memory stream like why
well because it's gonna get cold this
overload and it's gonna use the value
task are you gonna allocate less I was
like wow okay
Thank You Steven for you know doing that
overall I just want to caution people
like value task is awesome but there's a
you know basically the design guidelines
is that always used with with tasks
start with tasks sorry
don't use the value task it's really
advanced it's you know it's the value
task is really for the hot paths only
nothing else and and I'm gonna show you
a little bit more why so in you know we
basically came into value tasks like can
we improve it even more and in future in
the next versions actually what we
discovered that you know there's this
kind of one person pacing hands case so
most of the time you complete
synchronously and as you have seen like
everything is like on struct so you
don't allocate life is beautiful and but
when you have to switch to this to this
synchronous so to realize in her case we
have to allocate that didn't stop us and
in.net core 2.1 we actually introduced
one more option the a value task source
which is kind of another option on the
you know if you saw the tea and tasks of
tea and one thing I should have forgot
to mention we don't have the struct of
value task before before this thingy
because if it's that's for the void case
you cannot have you know of white you
know in generics we would be void it
would be task or void so it's only task
but in the presence of by value task
source you know you have that now I'm
not going to go into details but it's
basically again a waiter pattern almost
like that it can answer the questions
like are you completed hook me up to a
callback get the result and that stuff
and you know inside all that kind of all
the methods on the value task now become
ternary because only one of these values
can be known now or you know meaningful
so we have like instead of if task task
of T is not now then do this otherwise
do that you have like one more if check
in there and like ternary operations and
what the beautiful of this thing is that
actually it can it can reuse the task
catch them and reset them this is
something that we couldn't do because we
didn't know who holds up on
so this thing is actually enabled us
even do more you know more using that
you allocate something you keep it
around as soon as it's done you can go
reset that thing and use it for another
call later on which is actually used
heavily for example or heavily in
sockets when you have sent a sync or
receive a sync typically or not
typically but you know you have one
object pend percent and one object per
receive because you know you cannot do
two cents at the same time on the same
socket so what you can do you have had
you actually have the guarantee that as
soon as I'm done somebody kind of you
know completes that I can take that
object and use it for the next call on
the same on the same socket which is
kind of pretty neat and you get to zero
allocations for sockets kind of as the
overhead like it's it's pretty cool but
it's exactly why you know we don't want
people to do that or because it's you
have to be cautious you need to know how
you're calling that you have to take
care of stuff it's kind of like bringing
yourself almost to the C++ land when you
have to take care of memory you know
lifetime not don't screw up on that
stuff so it's easy to kind of mess up in
this thing and that's why we don't
recommend anyone to use it but it's kind
of cool thing that on the hot path
inside the BCL there it's most needed
it's used and there's like a couple of
you know high profile like you know high
performance libraries maybe five or ten
in the world that actually you do use
this because they get the value and it's
worth for them to kind of do into the
complications you know that are
associated with it now it's as well used
on network stream pipelines and channels
if you follow up latest thing and that's
not going to leave it off and do a quick
summary would we have learned hopefully
today and hopefully you find it useful
so we started with the AP and pattern
Places programming model from the
ancient times which was the icing result
begin foo begin end and the Troublesome
was actually it was limited nesting and
looping that was extremely complicated
especially in the synchronous way when
you wanted to optimize things then it
was there like short period of the EAP
event based thing which was same
problems as the APM so didn't help
relate much the next thing that was
introduced was tasks with the mate when
you block and continue it so anyone can
hook up to tasks and there's the
component of the task which is not that
much
known is the task completion source
which is this thing that can manipulate
with the task itself
we are internal methods then async/await
came along key takeaways is that
actually it's a beta pattern so it's
actually flexible it's not based on
tasks but its tasks like there are state
machines involved so behind the scenes
things are everything for you
and in.net course you know 2.0 quite
recently we introduced value tasks we
actually built on top of the abstraction
innovator pattern everywhere that you
know it's cool hyper
you know hyper optimizations are
possible but you have to be extracted
for so please don't use it it's
dangerous unless you're one of the ten
people in the world that's you know
really have the business need and really
want to go for the pain that's all thank
you very much hopefully you enjoyed that
[Applause]